[Music]
PC users weren't able to play Final
Fantasy 15 when it launched on ps4 and
Xbox one last year but there may still
be hope if director Hajime Tabata gets
his way I'm Matt and this gamespot news
update is available on PC Tabata told
Japanese publication from it sooo that
he'd like to release the game on PC as a
technical attempt he said I want to show
PC users Final Fantasy 15 running on
high in machines he continued to talk
about the possibility of pc exclusive
features such as making your own quests
and mods he also added that there are
currently no plans to expand 15s world
despite there being videos online that
suggests new areas could come to the
game the director says that doing so
would take a year to complete some fans
may not hold hope for a pc version but
it's worth noting that many games from
the series are available on Steam
including final fantasy 7 8 and 10 a PC
version of Final Fantasy 15 has not been
confirmed but we'll keep you updated if
it's ever revealed so for that and more
from the world of video games stay tuned
to gamespot
you